hey buddy  are you doing spider-man  that's me what's your name Nicholas nice  to meet you how're you doing  look at Tom Holland in full character  accent at all visiting the Presbyterian  Children's Hospital of New York so do  you like that man better he's fighting  me oh why is that what's better about  that man huh  oh did you really make sense for you  that's awesome buddy  yes he's more of a DC kid along for the  ride are two more spider-man homecoming  stars Jacob bats alone and zendaya who  is Michelle not Mary Jane I'm not Mary  Jane unfortunately but I am in your back  which is where you're not Mary Jane  another children's hospital visit Ciara  and Russell Wilson it's also important  to these kids for them to know how much  they inspire us and how much they mean  to us the newlyweds spent some quality  time doing arts and crafts with the kids  at the Seattle hospital  you